okay so when it comes to Batman I'm in
covering endgame you know when it comes
to Batman it's a very weird situation
and the reason why is because of well
because of Darkseid war Darkseid war was
basically the story that just threw a
wrench in everything right because you
had like Superman stories and you had
Green Lantern stories and you had Wonder
Woman stories and flash stories so on
and so forth and then suddenly it was
Darkseid war now for a lot of people or
for a lot of characters it sort of made
sense but for a Batman it caused all
kinds of problems and this is really
where the continuity sort of comes into
play with the whole DC you creativity or
a continuity and what-have-you but truth
be told if we wanted to if we so chose
we could just ignore Batman in games
we'd be ignoring an amazing story but we
could ignore Batman in game or we can
try to figure out where Batman in game
fits in this game of continuity with
regards to DC Comics so my initial
thought on this is that if we had to
kind of find a place to put it what we
could do is we could basically argue
that Darkseid war takes place between
between death of the family and endgame
or we could say it takes place after
endgame at some point in time we don't
really know what that point is Batman's
interest in the Joker is still prevalent
though during the events of Darkseid war
and so it would make sense that it could
possibly take place before that man
in-game the problem with this is that if
it did take place before Batman in game
then we would have seen it referenced in
Batman in game and so that's one of the
crazy things that goes on with regards
to little creativity versus continuity
so at the end of the day we're just
going to go ahead and like tack this on
as the story before the events of a very
you know really before going into DC
rebirth there are a couple stories like
I don't think graveyard shift is one of
them I think the next one is bloom and
the one after that is epilogue but those
are not wildly important those are
really just kind of stories that are
there for the offering of Bruce Wayne
with regards to the whole DC you Jim
Gordon Batman but that was not a really
well received line of storytelling so we
can just kind of pretend like that
didn't really happen I enjoyed it but
you know for the sake of continuity
we're really not going to worry about
that too much but in fact remains here
Batman in game is exactly what it sounds
like right I mean it's the final event
of the Batman comics I mean I know we
did in game at one point on my channel
here before those videos and I had
scripted I think those videos sucked and
so we're going back here and we're just
redoing it because I think this is
better
so because of that with regards to the
whole Batman in-game landscape it
creates a really interesting scenario
with regards to this final battle
between Joker and Batman and that was
really the nature of what it was that
Scott Schneider was hitting on Batman in
the Joker of a one-two punch of comic
books and the reason why is because of
the fact that the Joker is the most
popular villain and counter books I mean
consistently rated at number one at the
top of everyone's list the Joker is
popular because he's funny because he's
dangerous because he's kooky crazy no
one knows what it is he's going to do
the other half of this is that Batman is
rapidly becoming a superhero who's at
the top of almost everyone's list I mean
he consistently outsell Superman's
comics the only exception to that is
right now in DC rebirth where I think
that Superman is outselling Batman
because the comics are so good but
during the new 52
Batman was outselling Superman by about
50,000 issues a month it was crazy how
much better he was doing but the fact
remains that when it comes to these two
characters they're just kind of a
one-two punch of DC when it's good guys
and bad guys and because of that it was
always like the two went hand-in-hand
you could not have Batman without the
Joker you couldn't reboot Batman without
reintroducing the Joker somewhere along
the line Scott Snyder draws on that and
says the relationship between Batman and
Bruce Wayne transcends comics it
transcends the Joker schemes it goes
into this realm of something eternal it
goes into this realm in this you know
eternal battle between good and evil
because that's what it represents and so
picking up with this whole end game
conflict we initially joined Alfred
Pennyworth
giulia Pennyworth and n Bruce Wayne now
Julia pennyworth we can reference here
but we don't really need to know much
about her and the reason why is because
she has vanished in DC rebirth as far as
I'm aware as far as I'm aware she is
gone never to be seen or heard from
again and so because of this during the
events of Batman eternal which was
basically this year-long story that took
place between the events of death of the
family and endgame Julia pennyworth was
introduced as this girl who was the
alleged daughter of Alfred Pennyworth
and Alfred basically had a broader end
she became a part of the bat family but
she was really more of like the
information backup she was really one
that was just kind of there operating
behind the scenes very much in the same
capacity that we were traditionally used
to seeing Alfred Pennyworth perform and
so really she's just kind of like the
information person think of her as a
less significant smaller version of like
or
from Batman from Barbara Gordon when she
was in a wheelchair so in the middle of
their whole conversing and talking and
so on and so forth Batman's immediately
attacked by Wonder Woman now that's what
makes this so cool is because of the
fact that this is basically Batman
taking on the entirety of the Justice
League now Batman fighting the Justice
League raises as many questions as it
answers because if you talk to any
Batman fan they'll tell you oh yeah
Batman would easily be able to say oh
I'm Justice League
no questions asked I know that because I
like him but if you were to talk to like
a Wonder Woman fan they'll say no no
Batman could never take out Wonder Woman
Wonder Woman is way too cable well she's
way too strong I know that because I
like her Superman the flash Green
Lantern the whole nine yards people just
stick with the comic book fans that they
enjoy the most for example I'll say that
forevermore that Professor X is the only
good leader of the x-men nobody will
ever be as good as him I don't care what
people do with Cyclops
but the fact remains here that for the
character of Bruce Wayne one thing that
Scott Snyder has been doing the entire
time is just building on the nature of
him his intelligence what he's capable
of so on and so forth
and it's very much a reference to Tower
of Babel for those of you guys who don't
know tower Babel was a story that we did
a video on but it basically detailed the
idea that Batman had these different
protocols more or less on how to take
down each member of the Justice League
but with regards to this scenario it
really just kind of pops out of nowhere
and so Batman doesn't really have time
to enact these protocols and an argument
could be made that would regard to this
being the new 52 that maybe no such
protocols actually exist but regardless
of the scenario he does know how to take
down these different members of the
Justice League he does know how to
incapacitate them with the character of
Wonder Woman hand-to-hand combat is add
the question Bruce Wayne just does not
have the capacity to take her on she is
a warrior first and a woman second and
so because of that the ability to reason
with her isn't there because she's not
in her right mind she's not in control
of her full faculties and so as a result
Bruce Wayne's basically required to kind
of bring in this giant mecha-suit and he
does what he can he's able to hold her
off to a degree but then we actually
have her you know what she's kind of
defeated to a degree we actually have
the flash jumping into the scene now of
course this defeat of the flash is super
quick I mean it's just some kind of
liquid on the ground
this basically slick and it sends flash
careening into a building and that's
really it but notice Bruce Wayne does
this he incapacitates each member of the
Justice League and relation
- what way is easiest to subdue the
flash runs so put him on a ground is too
slick for him to gain any traction on
and suddenly he might as well just be
skating on ice Wonder Woman is a warrior
grab a suit that will allow him to
basically combat her you know using
hand-to-hand combat Aquaman is
essentially a fish out of water I don't
care what anybody says it's nature of
his character you know put him in a
situation to where he basically will not
be able to access water and eventually
you'll start wreaking havoc on his body
structure Superman is the kicker and the
reason why is because after all these
members of the Justice League have been
defeated Superman arrives on the scene
now this goes without saying
historically speaking you allow any
Batman story any Batman line of comics
to go on long enough Batman and Superman
will fight it's just the nature of the
beast it's the way it goes it's just
every single time it always happens that
way because we like to see them fight I
love to see Batman and Superman fight
but it always ends up going that route
now with regards to Superman's arrival
here what we're also basically shown is
that the Justice League is not in their
right mind because of the fact that the
Justice League have been joke arised
they have been infected with the Joker
toxin now this creates an even more
dangerous situation because it's not as
though you know Batman just there's only
you know he's just like stole Lois Lane
from Superman right it's all he's just
like your girl's mind now and he just
ran off with Lois Lane and that's the
end of that and she just bailed out on
Superman that's not the case you know he
can't talk to Superman down he can't
rationalize with Superman he's just
running amuck he's doing what he's told
by the Joker he's just influenced by the
Joker schemes and fighting against Bruce
Wayne the caveat to this comes in the
caveat of every Batman fight when it
comes to Superman invoking kryptonite I
cannot think of really any major
circumstance where Batman has fought
Superman and kryptonite has not been
invoked in some form or fashion and so
because of this we basically have Batman
using kryptonite gum more or less a
basically gun that has kryptonite
particles that he just spits to the eye
of Superman and that's what we bring
Superman down that's really it but it
also makes sense I mean that's the
struggle that you have when you have a
Batman and Superman a story where the
two of them are going to fight the
question is how do you have a man who's
really smart and really good at fighting
but has the normal strength and
abilities of a regular human being going
against a veritable god how do you in
that story effectively you do it the
only way you can do and you use Krypton
that is the crux of every argument when
it comes to Batman vs Superman on every
form everywhere across the world it's
always the idea well what if that man
didn't have kryptonite it's like well
then he would probably die and that's I
would be over really really quick and it
wouldn't be interesting at all and so
because of that we always you know end
up seeing kryptonite invoked here but
with the idea of the Joker basically
Joker rising the Justice League once
they're defeated in turn it's now on
Batman to begin going through and
finding out why now the reason why this
is such a huge deal is because for the
most part the Justice League have never
really been subdued by the Joker now
what this tells us is the length the
Joker is going to go to in order to try
to get his hands on Batman in order to
basically take this nail from the realm
of being a hey let's just run around get
into a fight to the realm of actually
being a dangerous scenario but at this
point we transition over to what's left
of Arkham Asylum now the reason why I
say that is because during the story
Batman eternal was basically dealt with
the idea of hush rallying the various
Batman villains and facing off against
Bruce Wayne Arkham Asylum was destroyed
in its entirety now there were a few of
the things that went into that but
ultimately it led to Wayne Manor being
confiscated and then transformed into a
new Arkham Asylum and so with that in
mind one of the orderlies who had worked
in Arkham was a guy by the name of Eric
border now Eric border had about five
comic book appearances prior to this
particular story and Eric was just a guy
that that men have worked with
occasionally where they were trying to
access like this cell of the Joker or
something along those lines but Eric was
always a background character that
nobody ever had any reason to question
he would just kind of show up for a
little bit and then he would do
something and that would really be it he
was as forgettable as virtually any
other character in comics the great
thing about Snyder writing is he says
yeah but remember that really
forgettable guy what if he was a very
important guy and what we end up having
here is Batman just kind of making his
way through Arkham eventually locked in
the cell by Eric only for Eric to
basically reveal the fact that he is the
Joker and so essentially what's been
happening this entire time you know
throughout all the Batman comics
following the events of death of the
family is the Joker has been there
watching Batman every step of the way
The Joker has been walking around Arkham
Asylum every step of the way and no one
ever had any reason to believe it was
him now there were a couple steps that
the Joker took in order to pull this off
the first was to basically use what
amounted to muscle relax
to keep his grand from giving him away
the other half was you know changing the
color of his hair changing the color of
his skin pigmentation or at least
covering his skin pigmentation and
making himself look like a normal person
but the reason why this is such a huge
deal and the reason why this was so
significant when it happened was because
of the fact that historically speaking
the Joker has always just would have
been viewed as this nonsensical comedic
character where he just kind of engages
in these goofy stupid acts he's not too
bright he's certainly not some you know
insane criminal genius he's just a guy
that you know does stuff Batman chases
after him or you know Joker gets locked
in Arkham Asylum he escapes and the
story continues again what Scott Snyder
is basically telling us here is that the
Joker is not some buffoon he's not the
same kind of goof that we've always
thought he's been instead he's a lot
smarter than he's previously been given
credit for he's a lot smarter than we
would traditionally think him to be but
in the social he was basically able to
trick everybody including the world's
greatest detective into believing that
he's either dead or he simply just
sitting underground when he was among
them the entire time and that's one of
the reasons why that's so cool and so
with that man effectively you know
locked in a Cell the idea is that the
joke is essentially going to run amok
throughout the entirety of Gotham City
he's going to unleash absolute
pandemonium and absolute chaos now the
problem with this little bit of
storytelling here is that Snyder kind of
has to jump around a bit and the reason
why is because of the fact that I would
imagine a to a degree this story was
probably fast-tracked if I were going to
be honest with you guys I would imagine
Batman in game was probably slated to be
a seven or eight issue story arc and I
certainly think it would have helped to
flesh out some of the small little
tidbits here and there but in this
instance we don't know how Batman got
out of his cell in Arkham Asylum he just
did now with regards to Scott's letter
you know having this happen
he doesn't in a couple different ways
he's like look guys it's that man he's
gonna find a way out I mean it's you
know he's not going to be stuck in a
prison cell forever especially not the
prison cell of the old Arkham Asylum
that he visited so many times before
surely he would just have to know the
ins and outs and he would always have a
way out and even if he didn't he was
just find a way out for himself whether
it's using something out of his
infinitely stored utility about to blow
the hole in a wall or whatever the case
may be he would always end up finding a
way out of this captivity and ultimately
go free and so the question that ends up
coming to fruition here is if the
citizens of Gotham City are basically
losing their mind
if they are being exposed to a joker
toxin well then why don't we just cure
it under normal circumstances that would
be the case the Joker has been using the
Joker toxin so many times it'd be very
easy to cure it'd be very easy to
eliminate the problem with this is that
there has been a new ingredient added to
the Joker toxin that Batman cannot
account for which means that it can't
just be cured not only that the true
spooky nature of the Joker begins to
come into fruition when we have
Commissioner Gordon just looking over
all these different details and stories
and so on of the Joker's past and what
we end up finding out is that over the
last you know some odd you know a few
hundred years or so in all these major
calamities and all these major events
and all these different terrible
scenarios and in everyday life or when
random pictures were taken we ultimately
ended up finding the Joker was there now
if what's being done in this picture is
absolutely true what we're seeing is
true that it means that the Joker is
some two hundred years old which is
absolutely mind-blowing in terms of how
it all unfolds because then the question
becomes if the Joker is 200 years old
then what does that mean for the
character of Batman
you know does it mean that Bruce Wayne's
is kind of living this repetitive life
or does it mean that someone like Bruce
Wayne has always been there taking bath
the Joker again it raises a lot of these
really interesting questions when it
comes to the two characters because what
Scott's not it was kind of dotting in
was this idea that the Joker could in
fact be this eternal god of chaos this
eternal god of destruction now it does
beg a few questions in terms of you know
how it comes together I mean this
story's older we've done this video
before we're just kind of remastering it
now so we really know how it ends but
just kind of let ourselves live in the
moment for a second it really is kind of
a cool scenario because it begs the
question if the Joker is the god of
chaos city was the god of order and
absolute destruction then how would that
unfold is he like an entity is he an
essence that just takes over one host
after another you know or if you
legitimately immortal well he always end
up just kind of being reincarnated and
you know his body will always resurrect
itself how does that all come together
that mystery that intrigue that kind of
Wow one of the world's going on the
cloak-and-dagger element of the Joker's
past is what makes this so possible
because no one knows the tried and true
story of the Joker
there's some origins and have more
credibility than others The Killing Joke
for example the Joker having been Red
Hood but the question is is that true
or is it just an idea that's maintained
because
no one knows the right answer is that
answer used in place of the absolute
truth it's basically supplying the best
thing we can offer for an answer because
we don't know what the real answer is
and so following this and the Joker's
effectively waging a one-man war against
everything that Batman knows and loves
and that's the basis behind this that's
the nature of this Bruce Wayne is
basically forced to see a repeat of his
own past in the form of Joe Chill now
for those of you guys who are reading
all-star Batman right now this is one of
the reasons why we're doing Batman in
game and this is one of the reasons why
the question of Batman in game
continuity comes into play because what
we end up having is the introduction of
Duke now of course Duke is basically a
boy who's forced to witness the same
real force to experience the same kind
of a violent scenario as the parents of
Bruce Wayne in the sense that he's
forced to possibly witness his own
parents being killed now of course
Batman jumping into the fray Batman
stopping - Joker eyes Joe Chill allows
Duke's parents to live the issue with
this is that they're exposed to the
Joker toxin and there doesn't seem to be
any way to cure it they're effectively
lost and so of course Bruce Wayne grabs
Duke and they associate take off that's
how Duke gets introduced to DC Comics
and that's why he plays a pretty
significant role in the life of Bruce
Wayne because his origin is almost
identical to the origin of Jason Todd in
the pre-crisis era of Dick Grayson you
know before crisis on Infinite Earths
and after crisis on Infinite Earths you
know the ideas that they had lost their
parents under some you know violent
circumstance and they're effectively
left an orphan just like Bruce Wayne not
only that these lengths that the Joker
will go to to secure is on end you know
to secure his campaign are shown to have
virtually no limits I mean there are
babies that are Joker eyes which is
pretty twisted and pretty screwed up you
know but of course we're Jim Gordon is
essentially making this case you know
he's talking directly to to Bruce Wayne
saying hey look you owe the Joker almost
comedy Joker almost killed me I managed
to subdue him ultimately you know the
Joker effectively comes back that ends
up taking out Commissioner Gordon not
really permanently not really killing
him I mean he stabbed him in the chest
with a with an axe so you would think
that would basically get him killed but
then we end up having you know like we
end up having Commissioner Gordon just
kind of pop up what is Joker toxin now
again at this point it's doing what can
be done in order to stem the tide of
absolute chaos of Gotham City and that's
really the significance of this moment
is because this city is just devolving
into complete and total pandemonium
you have soldiers who are Joker eyes and
they're just riding around in tanks
carrying out the Joker's wishes and once
you have people who are just ripping the
town apart I mean it's just absolutely
nuts and it's a really really cool
moment to see and it's a really cool bit
of chaos that goes on here and the
reason why is because there's always
been this sort of decorum with the
Batman landscape right like like things
get close you know things get close to
the point where maybe Gotham is a little
bit beyond redemption maybe it's a
little bit beyond hope but it never
quite crosses that line the city of
Gotham never quite steps off that ledge
there's really no one to push it there
and an argument could be made then all
the Joker is really doing here is
exposing Gotham for what it really is a
city that's just slowly spiraling out of
control and Batman doing the best he can
to stem the flow so what happens when
this wall just got these few punctures
here and there and water spewing in and
Batman's keeping the water coming in
with a little bits of gum what happens
when somebody starts blowing a hole in
that wall well there's no one to stem
the tide he's basically just revealing
Gotham for its true nature the insanity
of the city the fact that it's beyond
any real measure of Hub the fact that it
is a city that's quite literally just in
a state of self-destruction now of
course Bruce Wayne's journeys and his
desire to try to figure out what's going
on what just hidden chemical compound is
in this virus brings them to a villain
by the name of crazy quilt now as far as
I'm aware crazy quilt as he exists here
in the new 52 is a wholly new creation
or kind of a we work by Scott Snyder but
this is the first time we've seen him of
course he's a Jack Kirby character that
goes all the way back to really before
the new 52 and maybe even shortly after
crisis on Infinite Earths possibly even
before um but this is really just kind
of like a new iteration of him but he's
really just a guy who's kind of obsessed
with you know with you know science and
medicines and studies and so on and so
forth but he's a guy who always sort of
felt like he was playing second fiddle
and kind of left out of this bigger
circle of greater guys you know in
comparison like Hugo Strange and dr.
death and so on and so forth because
those are scientists in the community of
villains who are viewed to be the best
of their sort crazy quills just kind of
gets there to be like this B or C Les
Cayes and so what he's really doing here
and the reason why he's allied himself
with the Joker is so trying to solidify
himself as being one of the foremost
scientists in the realm of villainy and
the motivation behind this is a chemical
that's called Dionysian now this is
where Scott Snyder begins to move the
story away from like mythology and
weird mystery and intrigue and possibly
even some some ghost storytelling and
basically moves it back into the realm
and brings it back to being grounded in
science and in reality and structure at
least as close as you can get to reality
with a comic book but what snyder also
does is he invokes guys like Vandal
Savage he invokes guys like Ra's al Ghul
and he says these are not just mystical
beings you know Vandal Savage is not
some guy who is just inherently immortal
it doesn't work that way Ra's al Ghul is
not a guy who just stumbled across the
Lazarus Pit one day and just sort of
dipping himself in it the reason why
they are immortal is because of
Dionysian but Vandal Savage was the
first and only person to encounter
Dionysian in its most pure form Ra's al
Ghul founded but it's corrupted and it's
the reason for why whenever he tells
himself into the pool he comes out with
temporary madness the Dionysian that the
Joker uses is an even more impure
version and that's something that I hope
you notice that it's basically stages of
impurity that move you closer and closer
to madness the most pure version has no
side effects of complete madness an
impure version or willing to you a
relatively impure version can bring you
a temporary madness as in the form of
someone who emerges out of the of the
Lazarus pits and if a version is too
impure it'll simply drive you insane
which seems to be the case with the
Joker now of course with regards to
Dekker himself the motivation here is
that he was basically told by the Joker
look if you help me out I will give you
Dionysian it'll effectively make you
immortal and you can use this substance
for whatever you no desire whatever
dream it is that you have of course
against the wishes of Batman he injects
himself with this syringe and ultimately
his body begins breaking down on the
really on the on the genetic level on
the cellular level and he really just
kind of goes to pieces now of course
this is really Snyder kind of giving us
a timetable
it's him fast tracking things what we
end up finding out here is that with
regards to the Joker himself in terms of
like the pale man mythos it's what he's
been building on his entire life and his
entire existence and we'll get more to
that once we get closer to the ending of
this story but the reason why this was
fast-tracked and the reason why we're
given a really quick timetable is
because we're seeing what the end result
of sposa
- this virus is going to be there's
effectively a 24-hour window between the
time then a person is exposed to the
virus and the time that a person ends up
with the same faith as crazy-cool the
reason why he died so fast is because he
had it immediately ingested into his
bloodstream
whereas
individuals who breathe it in as a gas
have a little bit more time before they
effectively die and so because of this
that man takes the only route that he
can take in terms of trying to find out
what Dionysian is if it even really
exists in Gotham City and he travels
back to the court of owls now remember
the court of owls was this organization
that had existed for hundreds of years
we talked about that with regards to our
court of owls and Night of owls story it
was an organization that had been
existing as part of the criminal
underworld in Gotham for hundreds of
years and Batman didn't know about it
but the talents do have access to
something that is effectively able to
resurrect the dead this of course leaves
Batman to ask the question what is going
on
what do you guys know about this
substance have you ever used it now of
course this is again confirmation of the
fact that the court of owls uses
Dionysian to basically resurrect those
individuals who are talents and then
have them work for the court themselves
in addition to the electron chemical
that they have ingested inside of their
body by virtue of their bloodstream and
long term exposure again we covered that
in our video about night of owls but the
fact remains here then in the eyes of
the court the court are actually ready
to let Gotham City die and that's really
kind of the crazy situation about this
is because you would think that it would
just simply be a mutual desire to keep
that city going but that's not the case
the court basically makes the argument
look this city is going to die I mean
this city is going to be destroyed it'll
be rebuilt once the Joker leaves and
then we will again be rulers of this
city once it comes back to the way that
is supposed to be we would literally
guide it and mold it into the image that
we desire and so because of that you
know what we end up having is the Joker
essentially sneaking in the Batcave
again this is basically Scott Snyder
grabbing all these different elements
grabbing all these different things but
the instance where Batman has talked
about how somewhere along the line the
Joker had gained access to the Batcave
it's a reference to this yet again the
Joker has gained access to the Batcave
again the difference here is that alfred
tries to take them out with a shotgun
now this is kind of cool because this is
alfred being pretty hard-ass and we
really kind of know that what is
character when it comes down to it
outwards god of where it counts he's not
the strongest he's not the best fighter
but come hell or high water he will
protect the Batcave and Batman as best
he can and so Alfred of course his hand
is chopped off now this is why I say we
can really kind of look at the idea of
in-game and we can determine its
continuity for ourselves because Alvers
hand is not cut off in DC rebirth this
hand is well intact and
we managed to grow a new one I do not
believe there's an explanation of how
this reconciles with the existing Batman
NUI I think it's just kind of ignored
and it's just really just kind of left
there um it may have been reattached in
a story that I'm not familiar with but
as far as I'm aware like it was just cut
off and that was really the end of that
but with the Joker kind of going through
with this massive parade throughout
Gotham City as grotesque as it is
ultimately the bat family kind of stems
things off as best they can they do what
they can to kind of save the day but it
ultimately comes down to Batman actually
making friends with the various members
of its rogues gallery and again this is
really one of those scenarios where it's
just a mutually assured destruction M ad
if they don't act together and so it's
really in the best interest of the
various villains poison ivy Clayface so
on and so forth to work together in
order to bring the Joker down now this
also begins the process of us being able
to see Clayface
become a good guy and that's one of the
cool things it's slow it's a very very
slow build but these are the baby steps
these are the things that eventually
lead into that and so what is happening
is of course that man comes up with a
plan because as Batman and he's always
got a plan and the story's got to end
somehow and so but one of them happening
here is it's really like Dick Grayson
dressed as Batman serving to distract
the Joker and where the Joker initially
believes he's effectively taking control
of that man basically hasn't held
captive ultimately when the ruse is
revealed and it turns out to be Dick
Grayson the Joker immediately picks up
on the fact that Batman found died in
museum and so of course with the various
bombs planted around the die and you see
em - actually having been not really
deactivated but basically kind of held
off by Julia pennyworth what this does
is it leads to a final confrontation
between the Batman and the Joker now the
reason why this is so huge and the
reason why this is so important is
because Scott Snyder is doing a lot more
than just saying and it's Batman and a
joker fighting each other it's not like
that instead this battle is designed to
represent every ounce of conflict the
two have ever had every instance where
they've ever fight going all the way
back to Batman number one every instance
where the Joker and Batman have come
together they've engaged in some
campaign and the Joker is defeated and
egos Arkham Asylum this is designed to
be the story to end all stories the
battle to end all battles between the
Joker and Batman in the traditional
sense now as we know in DC rebirth we
will see like the three Joker's that's
really what's just kind of being hinted
at that's a story that's going to be
given to us and that of course comes out
of Darkseid war again a little bit of a
kind of a continuity going back and
forth
even the Joker himself really kind of
makes comments to the idea that it is
it's almost comedic they've been
fighting for so long they've been
enemies for so long this was really the
only end result this is Scott Snyder
hitting to the idea of like The Killing
Joke right you know when Batman goes and
he sits down he talks to the Joker and
says you know if we keep going one of us
is going to die it's grabbing all these
themes of Batman throughout the decades
of his storytelling and bringing them
all together into one cohesive story and
saying this was the most logical outcome
somewhere along the line there was going
to be a battle to the death between
Batman and the Joker now the funny thing
about this is that the Joker's sanity or
at the very least what seems to be the
illusion of sanity begins to basically
come to the surface when Batman
effectively prevents him from accessing
the Dionysian in order to basically go
through and heal himself from his
injuries and maintain his longevity but
in this moment of desperation the tables
are turned
Batman seems to be the insane one Batman
is one that doesn't care whether he
lives or dies he's ready to die with the
Joker the Joker struggling to live The
Joker struggling to come out on top and
that's why this is so cool is because
it's a reversal of what we're used to in
the last few moments of what seems to be
their lives Batman the Joker
switched places suddenly Batman's the
guy who doesn't care anymore and the
Joker's the one that cares about living
so again it's kind of a cool little bit
of a scenario here but and what appears
to be the death of Bruce Wayne we pick
up basically two weeks later with you
know the bat-signal basically being
broadcast out in terms of just memoriam
of sorts of that family of course
seaming degrees alfred definitely not
being able to get over this but it's
also this idea that even Alfred and
Julia have to come to grips with the
fact that it was inevitable that Batman
was going to die it was inevitable that
Bruce Wayne was going to die as Batman
because his life is tragedy that's what
his life is and it was never going to be
anything other than that because he was
almost like a martyr it was almost like
this idea of I'll fight as best I can
I'll stem off against the bad guys as
best I can but if I die maybe it'll
inspire other people to take up my
mantle and become even better City
heroes then I was as well just kind of
setting himself up for the purpose of
keeping the Batman legacy and keeping
the Batman mantle continuously going on
but with that being said guys we are
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
let's explain make sure you ask the sub
button to become part of the Rob forth
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like again we can really just
kind of drop it off here we know that
man's alive
so we know that he survived the
experience but we can go ahead and kind
of drop it off here wrap up our new 52
Batman explanation series let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
in terms of scott Snyder's Batman run I
think it's absolutely stellar and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you